[Música]
hola los invito a hacer un ejercicio que
piensan cuando piensan en la frontera
entre méxico y eeuu qué imágenes se le
vienen a la mente pero hay un truco no
se vale pensar en lo que dice este
hombre
no se vale pensar en lo que la
inaceptable situación de millones de
emigrantes
no se vale pensar en la situación que
ocurre cuando tratamos de cruzar alguien
trata de cruzar la frontera y no lo
logra no se vale pensar en la
inaceptable situación de discriminación
y grado de violencia que muchas
mexicanas y mexicanos o migrantes han
vivido recientemente en eeuu
la frontera es un lugar del que todo
mundo habla lo dicen las noticias
encienden hacen reportajes en libertad
jms gente en asia se entera de lo que
está sucediendo acá pero pocos conocen
lo que pasa en verdad más que los que
somos de aquí entonces el ejercicio que
quiero hacer el día de hoy con ustedes
es compartirles algunas de las lecciones
de la frontera me ha dado a mí
yo soy laura reina nací y crecí en
ciudad victoria tamaulipas y a pesar de
llevar 15 años de no vivir acá a mí me
llena la boca de orgullo decir soy de
tamaulipas soy de la frontera y no
importa la situación en la que he estado
desde que ha sido asesora del secretario
de gobernación
he estado poniendo trabajando en las
comunas de medellín hablando temas de
micro movilidad o viajando sola por
egipto o estando en la frontera en
chiapas a mí me llena me da muchísimo
gusto decir que pasé mis veranos en
ciudad o ayer mosúl tamaulipas que dicen
que es la ciudad de las tres mentiras no
es ciudad no es valle y no está hermoso
y yo siempre me he sentido muy incómoda
cuando alguien la describe así porque
este pequeño pueblito entre matamoros y
reynosa que es la frontera con eeuu y
que prácticamente nadie conoce y que
cuando lo mencionaba esté bueno y tú
donde pasaba sus veranos y yo pues en la
frontera en donde más al lado del río
bravo
me daban mucho coraje decir y escuchar
que la gente me dijera es una ciudad de
las tres mentiras porque es una mentira
eso que nos hermoso vallehermoso y la
frontera en general es profundamente
bella y es bella por su gente es bella
porque somos gente resiliente gente
grande silencio es el concepto de la
gente que se sabe adaptar y hacer frente
a cualquier situación
somos gente fuerte somos gente que no
importa las circunstancias siempre
tenemos la manera y las herramientas
para hacerle frente a las cosas y es por
eso que a mí me encanta este dicho
tamaulipeco que dice dondequiera lavó y
planchó no importa donde vaya con los
herramientas y elementos que tengo yo le
hago frente a las cosas y es por eso que
les quiero compartir hoy tres lecciones
que me ha dado la frontera para hacerle
frente a la vida y es que a nivel global
hay una discusión muy seria respecto de
que ahora no vamos a vivir ni 60 y 70
años sino 100 años eso dice la
demografía y eso implica muchos cambios
en términos personales
qué cómo le van a hacer las personas
para transitar de un trabajo a otro si
ya no vas a trabajar en el mismo trabajo
toda la vida que esté la vida va a ir
cambiando te divorcias o cambias de
ciudad y demás con qué herramientas le
haces frente a eso mucha gente se pierde
y entonces muchos psicólogos economistas
y demás están trabajando soluciones para
saber cómo las personas logran hacer
transiciones exitosas yo digo que no
tienen que ir muy lejos y que le pueden
venir a preguntar a nosotros los
norteños a nosotros los que crecimos en
la frontera porque no lo sabemos de papá
aquí tres razones la primera sabemos
cómo hacerle frente y la primera lección
es tener clara su identidad pinta tu
raya todos los que crecimos en fronteras
sabemos que es cruzar al otro lado es
decir ir a eeuu hemos hecho filas
larguísimas en navidad en año nuevo para
ir a comprar lo que queremos
hemos recibido discriminación de parte
de los agentes y migratorios que nos
dicen este y usted qué es
este mexicano saque su pasaporte todas
estas dinámicas locales de estar
reiterando a cada rato que eres mexicano
que tienes tu pasaporte y que lo usas
para cruzar al otro lado hace que tengas
muy claro quién eres tu nombre mi nombre
es laura tengo 31 años soy mexicana y
eso esa identidad te lleva a pensar
mucho más otras cosas no solamente donde
nací donde crecí sino quién soy y que me
gusta hacer y eso me ha pasado a lo
largo de mi vida porque me pongo a
pensar que es realmente el otro lado yo
estuve 10 años trabajando en el sector
público tengo dos licenciaturas una
maestría en administración pública un
doctorado en administración pública mi
pasión es servir y mi pasión es estar al
frente de personas y tomar decisiones
resolver problemas y siempre creí que lo
podía hacer desde el sector público
trabajando en el gobierno en un partido
político como activista social dando mi
opinión en programas de televisión
pero luego un día me encontré en el otro
lado y dije y si lo hago desde el sector
privado y si lo hago desde la desde otra
esfera desde otro espacio y me di cuenta
que tenía este ejercicio de cómo tengo
muy claro qué es lo que quiero hacer no
importa donde lo haga mientras tenga
clara mi identidad y pinte mi raya que
es una frase muy norteña que tenemos que
es hasta aquí llegó este es mi set y
bagaje de valores que tengo y con estos
les hago frente a la siguiente porque no
importa en donde esté yo voy a hacer la
misma persona no importa si estoy en
yucatán con un grupo de yucatecos y
empiezan a hablar cantado de su manera
yo siempre voy a hablar norteño y yo
siempre voy a hablar fuerte no es que
esté enojada es que así habló entonces
el otro lado no importa cuál sea
mientras tú tengas claro quién eres y
eso es una gran lección que tenemos para
la vida los norteños ten clara tu
identidad y no importan las fronteras
que cruces no te vas a perder
entonces no nos quitemos este orgullo
enorme de ser del norte primera lección
segunda lección ser resiliente
y decimos que significa resiliencia otra
vez se los explico es el ejercicio de
adaptarse de ser flexible nosotros
estamos acostumbrados a calor es de 50
grados en la frontera dicen por ejemplo
en mi caso de mexicalli que tienen esos
señalamientos que dicen estás seguro de
que quieres seguir y nosotros decimos
pues claro entonces nosotros estamos
acostumbrados a los calores a cualquier
clima y pasar de los 50 grados a los 10
grados y que luego llegue un huracán y
hacerle frente a eso estar listos para
lo que viene y en ese estar listos no
cualquiera lo logra porque no importa el
clima que venga en la vida no importa si
es un clima de calor o es un clima de
violencia o es un clima de incertidumbre
o es un clima con el cual no estás listo
hay dicen hay personas que dicen no es
que no sea mal clima es que no está lo
suficientemente preparado en otra es la
ropa correcta los norteños sabemos con
las herramientas que tenemos adaptarnos
rápido entonces no importa el clima en
la vida lo que importa es que sepas a
adaptarte que sepas ser resiliente que
sepas salir adelante
que sepas lo que nosotros decimos a
darle a las personas que estamos en el
norte sabemos también que nos morimos en
la raya y que en ese ejercicio de
resiliencia no nos preocupa tanto que si
estamos listos o no para la situación la
resiliencia es algo que viene
profundamente en nosotros y que las
personas por ejemplo ahora con la
preocupación del tema de cambio
climático y cómo están cambiando las
cosas vayan nosotros tenemos desde
siempre entendiendo eso y sabemos cómo
hacerle frente tercer punto usa tu
criterio no cierro decimos y en ese
ejercicio de usar tu criterio es algo
que pasa aquí es que estamos
acostumbrados a tener una libertad no
pasa en la gran mayoría de economía y
comercio por nuestras fronteras estamos
acostumbrados a tener opciones que si
hoy hablo español o hablo inglés cuando
cruzó la frontera que si compro la
gasolina de este lado del otro cual uso
horario
me conviene tener hoy cuando hay
diferentes usos horarios si acepta la
oferta o no cuando compro etcétera todo
el tiempo tenemos la capacidad de tomar
decisiones en un mar de opciones en un
espacio tan chiquito cualquiera se
pudiera perder pero nosotros no nosotros
tenemos muy claro nuestro criterio es no
a éste no le voy a hablar en inglés
porque le veo la cara y sé que sabe
español y me está hablando inglés nada
más por probar un punto y pues yo le
hablo español para probar otro y ese
ejercicio de esa decisión de ese en ese
criterio nos en en un mundo de opciones
nos lleva a preguntarnos existen las
fronteras
digo alguien nos puso un muro y hay un
río pero nosotros lo cruzamos todo el
día y nos pongan el muro nos pongan el
río o la vida nos ponga una
circunstancia nosotros sabemos cruzar y
saben que la mejor parte es que también
sabemos regresar y nos encanta no hay
nada más padre que cruzar la frontera
comprar lo que quieras pasártelo bien
pero el momento más bonito de todo ese
día es llegar a tu casa abrazar a los
tuyos tener claro
soy de acá entonces decimos acá en
tamaulipas no vengo a ver si puedo sino
porque puedo vengo y venimos todas las
veces a hacerle frente a la
circunstancia que pase o el momento que
o cualquier situación que ocurra
nosotros estamos listos entonces cuáles
son las tres lecciones de la frontera
para mí a 15 años de no haber estado
aquí de haber cruzado muchas fronteras
de haber de haber estado lejos de mi
familia de haber estado en diversos
países de conocer los 32 estados de mi
país y seguir buscando aprendiendo de
todos siempre me quedo con vaya lo que
necesitaba para hacerle frente lo he
tenido desde siempre y el privilegio de
haber crecido aquí
son las tres lecciones uno es identidad
en claro quién eres dos ser resiliente a
darle
usa tu criterio siempre y entonces
volviendo al ejercicio inicial que es
para ti la frontera que piensas cuando
piensas en la frontera yo creo que a
nivel global hay una narrativa respecto
de nosotros respecto de quienes los que
somos de aquí y mi ejercicio y mi
trabajo siempre es decir somos mucho más
que lo que ustedes ven entienden somos
mucho más que lo que ustedes ven en un
reportaje del new york times' como las
imágenes que les acabo de poner porque
porque en lugar de creerle el
preguntarle a la gente que está
trabajando en la frontera preguntan las
personas que le ponen agua en los alas a
los migrantes que van pasando
pregúntenle a los locales muchos de los
retos que hay a nivel global y la parte
en la cual no hay un diálogo real sobre
los problemas es que no le preguntan a
la gente entonces esta es mi propuesta
sobre qué es lo que la gente de la
frontera tenemos que decir y enseñarle
al mundo cuál es la suya cuál es su
opinión muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]